last question dr dallin are you sure the
perimeter surrounding the zone is really
enough
if a powerful emission were to occur we
would listen
the zone has remained stable for years
besides we didn't establish the most
advanced institution in human history
without first guaranteeing its safety
as the head of the scientific institute
for research of the chernobyl area or
circa for short i believe the wonders
that we will bring to the world far
outweigh the potential risks how big are
these risks exactly
the zone reveals a whole new world
we can stick with the old one fearing
change
but tell me
do you want our descendants to remember
us as cowards
or as those who dared to venture forward
to a new better humanity
the injured were evacuated i remind our
listeners that a similar incident
happened in our region quite recently
ruining homes and livelihoods
however city officials urge people to
stay calm assuring them the situation is
totally
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
you